chance is with us in Minnesota high
chance how are you hey Dave I'm doing
well how are you better than I deserve
what's up I have a question for you so
I've racked up about a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars in student loans
and right now I'm paying all the minimum
payments on time I'm making enough money
to barely make it by with enough money
like in my checking account where I feel
confident I have a thousand dollars
saved up in my savings account but what
I have my question say is my salary is
going to increase in the next year it's
contractually obligated to double so I'm
wondering what you think the best use of
that additional money would be whether
it's paying you know triple or four
times on my student loan payments or you
know saving it or sending this out for
retirement I'm just kind of getting some
advice from either we teach a process we
call the baby steps which is the order
of attack on your priorities of what to
do with money okay priority number one
is set aside $1,000 you mentioned that
that's maybe step one priority number
two the shortest distance between where
you are and becoming wealthy is to
follow these steps and we approve in
that with millions and millions of
people doing this okay it's not a theory
of mine it's a thing that tens of
millions of families have paid off
billions and billions of dollars in debt
and have become millionaires so it's
really really happening now is it a
get-rich-quick scheme oh absolutely not
it's very difficult so what is your
income now I bring him right around
twenty six hundred dollars a month okay
and so it's gonna double the fast gonna
double to five thousand so you're gonna
be making that's your take-home pace
you're gonna be making about seventy
five thousand dollars a year
I want you to live like a college
student and clean your dadgum mess up
and that's baby step to pay off all your
debts because the shortest path is not
to invest while you have student loans
the shortest path is get rid of the
dad-blamed student loans
as fast as you possibly can have no life
until you get this done don't talk to me
about your tire go back to work some
more and again and extra jobs